pour celui exactement jan de vries qui
conviendrait à nos techniques
vous avez une participation finalement
dans ce film participation ni amical et
morales a appelé direct par le
truchement de daniel guay chez qui j'ai
préparé mon bateau dans son chantier de
la richardais près de dinard un chai en
pays de connaissance
puisque nous parlons de votre bateau
justement je crois que les languedociens
ils sont très attachés car vous savez
qu'il a été conçu ici dans la région
cette très exactement par andré allègre
et ses 3 et bac c'est vraiment un génie
de la construction marine ont fait de la
conception marine pas écouté dont il a
placé deux bateaux dans les quatre
premiers de la transat avec kindy 4 et
de la première place et le cal 33 de jeu
original qui grillait les anglais pour
la troisième place et dans le quercy
français il ya peu d'architectes qui
peut se prévaloir de ce palmarès cette
année nous allons le public justement
qu'est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est pour moi c'est une
aventure extraordinaire et c'est un
monstre de métal à mondiale d'aluminium
qui fait un mètre soixante deux ans dit
m
dix mètres 60 de large pratiquement et
imaginé cette gigantesque plateforme
lancée dans les vitesses de l'ordre 15
18 20 25 parfois même 28 noeuds parce
que n'atteint pas une vedette en haute
mer dans les conditions de d'une vague
filiale lorsqu'il y avant qui
ressuscitait ces vitesses 20 jours et
quelques heures entre un homme et ce
bateau il doit se passer quelque chose
mais l'homme lui même
comment est-il psychologiquement au bout
de ses seins jour et pendant ces 20
jours
extelia une solitude du navigateur
solitaire et une solitude absolument pas
on est en course et physiquement on sent
la présence des autres concurrents sur
l'océan et puis il ya ce but de gagner
gagner à tout prix chaque minute chaque
seconde on ne pense qu'à faire marcher
le bateau au maximum il ya il n'y a plus
ni jouons ni nuit n'est ni heures de
repas ou heures de travail il ya 24
heures où le bateau doit marcher le plus
vite possible sur la route la plus
directe possible pour être premier
report et les squares psychologie sera
menace à gagner à tout prix
et quand on en bave et bien tant mieux
on est là pour ça